fries and put upon the Friday also
Gomez's is opposing Twitter hashtag
teach me senpai and what you want to
learn that I'm going to teach you
whatever you want because I'm the
almighty and all knowingly and all
beautiful there we go teach me senpai
how to eat Nutella the right way just
[ __ ] put it in your mouth like can we
teach me senpai how to be fabulous
followed by example teach me senpai how
to kiss a doggy come on
Oh disgusting come on like you never
make out with your dogs stop stop no
teach me some pie how to parkour alright
ah
you pull my carpet I will destroy you oh
yeah video teach me senpai how to
bitch-slap a [ __ ] it's easy all you got
to do is [ __ ] this happen
teach me senpai how to walk along a
crocodile
teach me scent by how to play Minecraft
alright welcome to Minecraft and just
gotta get the video hahaha
teach me scent by how to scream like a
girl
alright here we go ahh
teach me some buy how to peel off a
banana Jesus drill my finger each we
sent by how to shape that eyes okay
excuse me you all just want me to do
really gay and weird shake is that a but
there's anything wrong with being right
all right you know what I'm sick of it
I'm not gonna do it anymore
it's just not teach me some pie how to
do this with my hand all right let's
give it a go ah how the [ __ ] do you
finger peep oh I got it ah cut away
untie it teach me some pie how to get a
lots of sons
Oh bah-bah alright brother
hope you enjoyed this video if you did
hit that like button for every like you
save a Cody pine fingered leave more of
your teach me some pie in the comments
and I might teach you how to do it
for now I hope you have a great
breakfast